Another view which you may not have previously thought of
as a view is I call the book reporting view.
If you've got a, a system you're developing most shops will have some kind of
tool for reporting bugs.
These are bugs during development or
these are bugs after delivery, and those bug reporting tools often have fields
which you fill in which indicate which component does the bug relate to.
I'm suggesting that those components had better correspond to the architectural
components in your other views otherwise there's the potential for
some kind of confusion.
Okay?
Similarly, with respect to features, you would like
the person who's handling the bug to be aware of, well, this particular bug
arose when the following feature was being used by the, by the user.
Here's a screen capture from a get based web browser
interface into a source control system in which bugs are being listed with
respect to a particular component of that system.